good morning believe nation welcome
welcome Friday gratitude journal I'm
stream number 20 it's awesome to be back
to have you here uh what we do every
week day 9 a.m. eastern we share three
things that we're grateful for I believe
it will help you be a happier and
healthier entrepreneur and go and
achieve your big dreams and goals check
this out on my tea today can you read
that oh now you can't read oh it looked
like this about the focus is it gonna
focus focus no okay I'll read it for you
an attitude of gratitude brings
opportunities that's yogi tea this
morning so the two keys one is that it's
consistent that is daily it's everyday
it's not just once a week or once a
month or once a year it's every single
day into that you actually feel it that
you take a few seconds to reflect on why
those things are important to you
because just listing things off won't
help you until you actually feel it
emotionally somehow if you want to get
the benefit you've got to feel it
emotionally so I'm going to share three
things I'm grateful for I want you guys
in a live chat to share three things you
are grateful for and for everybody
watching afterwards leaving the comments
below don't just watch this video take
action leave it down below you do it
consistently you'll be a happier and
healthier and more successful
entrepreneur so I'm going to get started
I'm grateful for you guys uh in the live
chat for joining me every day and doing
this it's been a fun little experiment
with 20 days in when I started it was a
you know I didn't know what would happen
you know as entrepreneurs you should be
trying different things constantly and
I'm really grateful for you guys being
here and joining me daily for this one
of the things that I would do in the
morning would I would always go to the
chat and
and say what do you people for to kind
of start off the comments and recently
Jay your eyes and today's a no have been
doing it for me so zana started today
off good morning afternoon evening or
night what do you greet before so it's
awesome to have people leading off the
chat without me having to do it every
day so I appreciate you guys for doing
that um number 2 i'm grateful for all
the all the practice and growth i'm
getting in doing these videos yesterday
ended up having eight live streams the
last one didn't work out on timing 28
live streams and it's basically all day
practicing practicing answering
questions practicing interviewing others
practicing being interviewed and I'm
getting better you know I'm loving it
I'm loving the process and I'm getting
better and I don't know where it's all
going to lead but you know the quantity
leads of the quality and I'm getting I'm
super appreciative for the growth and
the opportunities you know one that
people want to talk with me and you know
we're doing these we have enough people
to fill up you know eight or nine and a
day but I feel the growth and and I'm
excited by in the future potential there
so super grateful for that it was a
really fun day yesterday and the Blue
Jays one they stomped 10 the one that
was crazy what an awesome game go jays
sorry for any texas fans out there and
my number 3 i'm just i'm people for
today you know we got a lot of stuff
planned i have a lot of Friday's my my
data work on projects and I've been
looking forward to it this week and
there's some fun things that I gotta get
through today so we're doing this we're
doing the business QA right after on the
on twitch and then it's going to be a
day of project work so I'm pretty I'm
pretty pumped up and excited about that
my schedule is usually one day a week
I'm doing different things so Friday's
project work wednesdays video day thurs
is interview live stream day and that
frequency works well for me because then
i look forward to it like i miss it a
miss project day it's been a week so i
want to get into my projects right and
then you know come next thursday of the
guy i want to do more interviews and
come next wednesday i want to do my
videos and so I like the anticipation in
the the chunking out it works well for
me at least so I'm super grateful happy
for today of doing my doing my projects
so we have five minutes I want to go
over what you guys are grateful for
today I do some shoutouts we got Zeno
the body part of the day is my elbows
and knees so can bend my arms and legs
kind of important think about what it
would be like without them I love it
there's all these things that you just
take for granted every single day in
your life that if you just thought about
what it would be without them your life
would be totally different so I love it
thank you number two public
transportation for getting me where I
need to go of course my legs and feet
when a distance is small I like it and
number three Rishi Cup TVs live stream
later today you don't mind this plug do
you Evan that's cool what's the live
stream about let's check this out Rishi
cups doing a live stream check the link
at the top let's catch up friends friday
episode 31 at one p.m. eastern all right
i'm gonna leave a comment and you leave
it oh the chapters disappeared today ok
forget it one o'clock rishi kept TV live
stream super excited alright what else
rishis in the chat Rishi has a cup of
morning glory I like it thank you for
California because the west coast is the
best coast I don't know about that but
we will have our difference of opinions
I respect that number two for donuts I
love that and number three for a leave
when I have any pain preferably the gel
caps is that is that like advil what's
it Oh for oats oh good good what else we
got up got a kind of
of YouTube with their scroll every time
but kale beyond good morning errbody
good morning man what's up sky's the
limit good morning maha Ville here for
moral support will check the video later
feeling the love man kalb and is
grateful for number one focus t25
because of the lobby to take to make a
daily habit of exercise and lose 24
pounds as of today don't know what that
is but congrats that's some awesome
gross growth is it gross growth what
else J rising the chair is in the room
to hear new future builder good morning
good morning J reyez thankful for living
downtown for creativity inside and fresh
views for transportation systems that's
a second transportation shout out today
everybody going ride the subway today
this show some love for your
transportation system for awareness and
leverage of social trend societal trends
for the growth and thriving of everyone
around me love it praveen good evening
Tamara hey guys love it Kail being
grateful for my restroom because I'm
able to use it without having to go
outside like back in the day indoor
plumbing super important I yoosh I
haven't helped me grow them suffering
from no habit of studying questions join
the live stream on Twitch happening in
two minutes what do we got what do we
got what do we got chatter chatter
sherry people to be here with all your
amazing people welcome back sherry we
love you made it through the surgery
awesome congrats of the long road to
healing Rasheed hello thanks from
Uzbekistan welcome Rasheed kob and I'm
grateful for my doggie Chloe a
Rottweiler I used to have a robot
because she's so sweet and it's always
giving love people underestimate
Rottweilers I think they're they're
super vicious but they're massively
carrying a new future builder I'm
grateful for being able to interact with
amazing people here on YouTube that's
right build the best community on
YouTube right here if the leave nation I
love it Tamara
I'm grateful that I got most of my video
this morning before running out of
storage I hope I hope you didn't lose
something that would suck but that's
awesome a vehicle for Stacy good morning
attitude of gratitude triple ! Stacy's
on fire this morning rape rape raekwon i
hope i pronounced that okay grief of
being on the wake up in the morning some
people don't wake up in the morning
right that's a pretty scary and for
family I love it WG consultants hello
sir from Tokyo ng consultants hello
hello back at UW + g consultants her
raised on board hello hashtag believe
Oliver grateful for the week and that I
always have something meaningful to do
super important I'm I was grateful for
the meaningful work I'm about to do
today I love it and the grief and the
meaningful work that we're doing right
now I love it well guys it's nine ten
that's it we're done i will see you on
Monday otherwise if you want to join us
on the live stream are going to twitch
we're doing business QA Jay rises in the
house Rishi cup TV in the house if I
don't see you there have an amazing
close to the week go out and crush your
projects pour your heart into some
meaningful work today continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you soon